لقد غيّر covet 19 بشكل جذري طريقة
تفكيرنا في مكان العمل
لأصحاب العمل الذين يعيدون الموظفين بأمان
إلى المكتب ليس بالأمر السهل ،
لكن بعض الشركات تقول إن تتبع
موقع الموظفين باستخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي
يمكن أن يساعد في التباعد الاجتماعي
وتتبع جهات الاتصال ،
وهو ما
يبني الصورة  برنامج الكشف
لكاميرات المراقبة الحالية
ما تحتاجه للكاميرا هو أن تكون قادرًا
على فهم مكان وجود الأشخاص
في الفضاء ثلاثي الأبعاد على الرغم من
أنها مجرد صورة ثنائية الأبعاد
توضح أن البرنامج يمكنه تتبع مدى قرب
الموظفين من بعضهم البعض وما إذا
كانوا  ترتدي قناعًا
تحاول شركات أخرى مثل Estimote
أن تفعل شيئًا مشابهًا
ولكن من خلال تتبع مواقع التكنولوجيا القابلة للارتداء
بقدر فهم مكان وجودك
من حيث موقعك المحدد ومن
ثم هناك مكان الأجهزة
وأو كيف هي  التواصل مع
بعضهم البعض عندما يقترب الموظف الذي
يرتدي أحد أجهزة تقدير الأسعار من
الآخر  جهاز الموظف ،
الجهازان القابلان للارتداء يتواصلان مع بعضهما البعض عبر إشارة lte
تفيد بأن التفاعل يتم تسجيله على
خريطة يستطيع صاحب العمل تتبع
كلتا الشركتين ، ويقول إن الهدف من هذه
التقنية ليس تحديد
الموظفين الفرديين على الفور ،
بل تهدف إلى التحسين
مساحة العمل لأغراض تتعلق بالسلامة ،
يمكنك أن ترى أن لدينا مشكلة حيث
ينتقل الأشخاص ويتحولون في الساعة 8
صباحًا ، لذلك دعونا نتأكد من وضع
الأقماع مع علامات الشريط على الأرض
أو في
بعض الأحيان يضع الأشخاص
أجهزة مراقبة المدخل خلال
الفترة التي يقضيها الأشخاص  تغيير نوبات العمل
أو التحولات المتقطعة ،
لذلك من المفترض أن تكون أداة إدارة
لإخبارك
بمكان مشاكلك والمكان الذي
تحتاج إلى إجراء
تغييرات فيه ، يقول استطلاع آخر أجرته مجلة macworld
أن واحدة من كل خمس شركات قد
فحصت ملفات الكمبيوتر الخاصة
بالموظفين الذين يتتبعون الصوت أو البريد الإلكتروني.  في مكان العمل ، ليس هناك أي شيء
يُسمح للشركات الجديدة قانونًا
بالتحقق من رسائل البريد الإلكتروني الخاصة بالعمل
والمكالمات الهاتفية الخاصة بالموظفين لعقود من
الزمن  يشعر خبراء فاسي بالقلق من أن تتبع
مواقع الموظفين المادية
باستخدام هذا النوع من التكنولوجيا ليس هو
الحل الأفضل لمنصب عمل 19 في
مكان العمل ،
فلا يمكنك إلقاء اللوم على صاحب العمل لكونه
قلقًا بشأن التواصل الاجتماعي ،
لكن امتلاك كاميرات فيديو من الجدار إلى الجدار يعد
إجابة رهيبة
.  ليس مجهولاً ، لا يمكن لصاحب العمل فعل
أي شيء بشأن اثنين من الموظفين لا
يباعدان اجتماعياً إلا إذا كان يعرف من هم
المقدّرون ويصرون على أن
تقنيات التتبع الخاصة بهم تحافظ على
خصوصية بيانات الموظفين
وأن الأمر متروك في النهاية
لأصحاب العمل للتأكد من أن التكنولوجيا
ليست كذلك.
لا نجمع أي معلومات
حول المستخدم بخلاف ربما
شيء تعطينا الشركة لإنشاء
اتصال سياق بالجهاز بحيث يمكن
أن يكون مثل معرف الموظف ومن
وجهة نظرنا ليس لدينا أي فكرة عن
ماهية أو من هو
الشخص الذي ينظر إلى الفيديو
إذا تعرف عليك
تمامًا كما لو كان يراجع أي
فيديو أمني آخر ، فحينئذٍ نعم
هناك طريقة
تتعجب بها  د تدرك ولكن في البيانات نفسها
لا توجد
معلومات تعريف شخصية
لا يزال المدافعون عن الخصوصية يجادلون بأن
الموظفين أنفسهم يمكن أن يكونوا بنفس
الفعالية
بدلاً من مراقبتهم باستخدام هذا
النوع من التكنولوجيا ، إنها
مجرد هذه العادة الانعكاسية
لأصحاب العمل الأمريكيين الذين يفترضون
أنهم يجب أن يأتوا  من الأعلى
مع مراقبة المراقبة
بدلاً من العمل مع الموظفين
لحل المشكلة